avec n'oublie le morneau au ministre des
finances du canada il est à toronto
bonsoir monsieur morneau et bonsoir
le baril de pétrole est à 3 4 $ en
alberta monsieur kennedy disait on s'en
va vers un taux de chômage de 20 25 pour
sa déficit probable en alberta de 20
milliards de dollars
j'avais fait quelques annonces
aujourd'hui mais ce que vous allez en
faire beaucoup plus pour l'industrie
pétrolière
c'est vous avez raison c'est clair que
c'est une situation très difficile en
alberta et c'est pour ça que nous avons
considéré comment nous pouvons mis leurs
situations pour presser pour le alberta
pour le terre-neuve a aujourd'hui on a
annoncé des mesures pour pour le crédit
pour les entreprises d'une taille
moyenne et ça assez à notre avis très
important mais être le fait a fait à
lille vont en faire plus de choses pour
autant le niveau de crédit et il n'y a
pas une limite ça veut dire qu'il ya
s'il ya le demande pour le crédit des
compagnies on va avoir la possibilité
d'avoir plus donc ça c'est très
important pour nous les choses
importantes pour les compagnies a trouvé
le pays et ça veut dire que dans le
secteur des logis dans le secteur de
transplantation dans nos secteurs
d'hospitalité dans le secteur culturel
nous voulons avoir une prend d'ici à
l'avenir et le niveau de crédit et est
très importante pour les entreprises et
c'est ça qu'on a délivré aujourd'hui
pour le secteur d'énergie et on va aussi
avoir une approche dans les prochaines
journées où on va avoir des crédits pour
pour tous les acteurs de l'économie qui
ont besoin et ça c'est parce que nous
voulons avoir une possibilité d'avoir
une bonne économie après les crises à
valga de l'entreprise ans vous avez
évoqué de l'aide pour les grandes
entreprises
c'est pas l'aide c'est le crédit ça veut
dire que nous devons avoir accès au
crédit
mais oui ce pour les grands pôles pour
les entreprises de tel
chaque taille ça veut dire que nous
avons commencé avec les entreprises le
plus petit avec notre prêt d'urgence de
40 mille dollars
et après ça une ligne de crédit avec le
bdc bdc pour les plus grandes
entreprises
aujourd'hui c'était pour les entreprises
d'une taille médium moyenne taille
et bien sûr on a besoin d'avoir les
autres approches pour les plus grandes
compagnies qui vont avoir une problème
comme air transat ou à aircanada ou à
l'ouest diaby et a sûrement des
compagnies avec avec des défis et nous
voulons avoir accès des crédits pour
nous sommes en train de considérer l
approche appropriée et dans les
prochaines jours on va avoir plus à dire
le fmi prévoit une baisse de plus de 6%
du produit intérieur brut au canada hier
nous avions eric girard le ministre des
finances du québec qui nous disait qu'il
s'attend à une baisse de 5% du pib au
québec
quel est votre prévision à vous pour le
canada
je peux pas avoir une sorte de
procession qui est faux ça veut dire que
on n'a pas une formation pour être
certain de notre pb ça c'est ça c'est
clair que ça va être difficile à vous
aider vous il ya quelques jours le
banque du canada on dit que c'est très
difficile à considérer exactement la
situation mais non mais qu'est ce qu'on
sait on sait que la situation est
difficile
on sait que c'est nécessaire de protéger
les gens les familles et c'est pour ça
que nous devons considérer la prestation
d'urgence la subvention salaires réels
s'est en même temps menacé sert de
protéger les compagnies pour l'avenir et
et c'est ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
avec eux accès de crédit on va continuer
avec cette approche et c'est clair
qu'après on va avoir une économie qui
est plus robuste si on fait des choses
nécessaires
aujourd'hui si les gens continuent avec
leurs proches de protéger leur famille
avec à la clé les mesures d'être chez
eux comme ça non mais
mais je pense que les canadiens veulent
en savoir davantage sur la suite des
choses le président trump a présenté un
plan de réouverture de l'économie en
trois phases
est ce que vous allez faire ça à offrir
cette information là aussi aux canadiens
ce que je peux dire quand on a assez
d'informations aux à reconsidérer le
prochaine étape maintenant nous sommes
vraiment dans le crise on on a une
situation qui est un peu différent dans
chaque province ça c'est certain mais
nous nous habitons ensemble ça veut dire
que c'est nécessaire de considérer la
situation à travers le pays et
maintenant c'est nécessaire de
considérer exactement ce qu'on est en
train de faire je comprends mais aux
etats-unis ils ont faim quand et a donc
ils doivent tenir compte et le président
l'administration présente quand même un
plan de réouverture en trois phases
pourquoi on n'aurait pas ça nous ici au
canada
on n'est pas encore prêt d'avoir un
devoir de voir les prochaines étapes
bien sûr nous considérons en même temps
comment nous pouvons avoir une proche
avec le testing qui est nécessaire de
choses comme ça mais maintenant vraiment
gens disent que je voudrais dire c'est
une tente où on doit considérer à nous
mêmes à ce qu'on doit faire pour me lire
et notre situation est donc ça c'est les
choses le plus important quand on a plus
d'une formation quand on peut avoir une
approche qui est clair on va avoir plus
à dire allez vous présenter un budget à
bien sûr qu'on sait c'est une bon temps
on va on va considérer les prochaines
étapes au niveau fiscal assez certaine
que je dois être à transparent
aujourd'hui chaque journée hier j'ai une
une rendez vous avec le comité de
finance dans le parlement
c'était ce zoom a donc c'est comme ça on
doit faire maintenant mais quand on dont
nous sommes dans une situation plus
normale
on va considérer une projection de notre
situation fiscale
ça va être une france en a mais
maintenant nous nous continuer continuer
wonder qu'une approche qui est
transparent qui a beaucoup d'une
formation a eu pendant que nous nous
nous devons que ça de vrai comment nous
pouvons nous protéger
bien merci beaucoup monsieur mono pour
cet entretien ok merci beaucoup